A long time ago, there lived a princess in a beautiful country.
She was young and lovely.
She liked playing with a ball.
What about this golden ball for princess' birthday present?
That's a good idea! She will love it.
On the princess' birthday, the king gave the golden ball to her.
Wow, it's beautiful. I love it!
Thank you, dad.
The golden ball became the princess' favorite toy.
One day, the princess was playing with her golden ball by a pond.
La, la, la, la.
The princess threw up the golden ball and caught it as it fell.
I can throw it much higher.
But she threw it up so high that she couldn't catch it.
Uh-uh, oh no!
The golden ball fell into the pond.
The princess began to cry.
Oh, my golden ball.
What am I going to do?
She cried louder and louder.
The princess couldn't stop crying.
Just then, a frog came out of the pond and said.
Lovely princess, why are you crying?
Uh? How amazing!
The frog is speaking!